[Music]  she's tracked okay okay okay  how many can you save 11 species blues  the last of her kind if you'll never  capture her we thought you might know  someone who could help a rescue op what  could go wrong hey blue  you know me come with me hey no you  can't stay here it was all alive  the man who proved Raptors can follow  orders you never saw how many millions a  trained predator might be once  there is seldom Nabu they need it for  something else they need it  this is the most dangerous creature that  ever walked the earth  I say we shut this whole thing down  hey girl you think what I'm thinking  genetic power has now been unleashed  you can't put it back in the box  if I don't make him back  remember you're the one who made me come  here I'll be all right  these creatures were here before us and  if we're not careful they're gonna be  Hereafter welcome to Jurassic world  [Music]  you